Venezuela does not have enough food to feed
its 30 million residents.
It also can’t guarantee them electricity.
Or medical supplies in its hospitals.
It’s a country staring down social upheaval,
political unrest, and bordering on economic
collapse.
States of emergency have been declared.
So how did this happen to the country with
the largest oil reserves in the world?
For years, subsidized oil bought Venezuela’s
government influence abroad and popular support
at home.
But collapsing oil revenue in an economy dependent
on it has caused civil unrest and calls for
the ouster of the unpopular President Nicholas
Maduro.
Maduro has responded with mostly successful
attempts to consolidate his power and squash
opposition, nudging Venezuela’s democracy
towards dictatorship.
Here’s the situation…
Venezuela’s current crisis started long
before Maduro with his predecessor, the late
President Hugo Chavez.
Chavez revolutionized Venezuelan politics
with a left-wing ideology called “Chavismo”and
a fiery anti-U.S. rhetoric,
While in power, Chavez focused all
the country’s resources on one thing: producing
oil.
This meant that almost everything Venezuela
consumed besides oil needed to be imported.
And Chavez borrowed a lot of foreign money
to fund it all.
While oil prices were high, it worked.
Then, in 2013, the first domino fell: Chavez
died.
Maduro took over for Chavez, and in 2014,
the second domino fell: the price of oil started
to crumble.
Revenue from oil accounts for 95 percent of
Venezuela’s export earnings, and when prices
for the commodity began plummeting, Venezuela
found itself suddenly short on cash.
The government responded by slashing imports
like basic groceries and medical supplies
to avoid defaulting on its foreign debt.
It also started printing money causing inflation
to surge into the triple digits without an
end in sight.
The economic freefall has exacerbated social problems
It's gotten so bad that food shortages prompted
major riots.
A coalition opposed to Maduro won a majority
in the National Assembly in 2015 but its attempts
to remove the President from office have failed.
Maduro recently forced the formation of a
task group called ‘la constituyente’ to
rewrite the country’s constitution.
Less than a day later, he had two opposition leaders thrown back in jail, snatched from their homes at gunpoint in a midnight raid
And then there is the July 30th election.
All of the opposition candidates boycotted
so the only options was to vote for presumed
Maduro allies.
The assembly has broad powers including oversight
of every other branch of government.
After the election, the U.S. Treasury imposed
sanctions on Maduro's assets.
All assets of Maduro subject to U.S. jurisdiction
are frozen.
The U.S. is Venezuela’s largest oil consumer,
so wider sanctions would almost certainly
be devastating
Now here's the argument
Maduro's critics say that he has botched the presidency so badly he should resign immediately.
However some say the alternative isn't much better
The opposition alliance is made up of more than a dozen political parties with no unified plan to fix the economy,
and no leader to do it.
Venezuela owes almost $90 billion in foreign
debt over the next 10 years, and oil prices
aren’t likely to hit the previous highs
that kept the nation afloat, raising chances
that the country could default.
For now, citizens are stuck with a failing
economy and a leader focused largely on staying
in power.